so i think it's just they knew me so
that by the time it came around
um
that smallville was auditioning
they brought me in
how many times did you read for it
don't say it once
once for karine and once for greg
but then i had to test
then you had the test yeah
and then we were arguing about this on
the weekend i still had to get the pass
from walling
the week the two days before a week are
you serious
he says no no no but it was like totally
sure
so you had to pass casting you had to
pass greg beaming executive producer
smallville you had to then go test for
the network and the studio fly down la
yeah so i tested for them i came back
saturday i had to come to the
studio and do um tests you know for
wardrobe and hair and all that and then
they're like oh and welling it um lily
calm on tom is here and you're gonna
read a scene with them and i was like
okay cool it's neat it'll help for
monday's work
but i was still kind of scared and of
course then you know me somebody who's
cast the show and then i'd seen him on
the show and i walked out and he was
lumbering in and i just turned and
walked right into it i was like oh
it's just so weird for me
and we went in and read the scene i
thought okay that went great but i
didn't know
that that was my final goblin
you what
the final gauntlet like if he had hated
me he could have punted me that was it
so you're arguing about he says there's
no way i could have and i was like
[ __ ] tom you're being if he said i
have no chemistry with her guys this
isn't working they wouldn't have done it
yeah and here i was again chick from
alberta no clue thinking i got the job
we'll just read it'll be nice and i'll
see you on monday but i didn't know like
if you thought it was like dog made or
something really super annoying i mean i
know i'm annoying but annoying to the
part of like
i i couldn't bear to be in a room with
this person i don't think you're
annoying at all i think you're really
quirky and lovable you're quirky let's
let's redefine that as
really high energy i've said that many
times on the weekend and i met this very
high energy
wait a minute so you just saw tom you
were in vancouver for an autograph
signing for a con yeah and he told you
you have very high energy yeah well he
was talking in the panel right and he
was talking about how did you guys get
mad and you meet each other
and then he talked about my high energy
i never would have thought you
really kill you guys